I am pretty convinced that we are in the
last
stages
of
[Music]
of the ability for America to survive
we are in an end game right now and that
is not a liberal end game or a
conservative end game
a combination of both and we are
without Mercy
and we are without forgiveness
and we have to
we have to rethink that we have to get
it back into the earliest years
of public schools so that your your
civic education is complete
by High School graduation
it has nothing to do with college or
university
and the more you explore that
the more you'll see why that's simple
and common sensical
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
an academy award-winning actor author of
one thought scares me we teach our
children what we wish them to know we
don't teach our children what we don't
wish them to know
and a guy with a lot of moxie Richard
Dreyfuss welcome to the Reuben report
hiya
Richard you do have a lot of moxie for
some reason that line seemed like the
one that I should go to in the intro I
could have gone through about 800 movies
how do you feel about a lost in Yonkers
reference right up top
[Music]
um
um for some reason every bio of me
starts out with what a cocky arrogant
guy I am or was or something and uh
I don't really I don't agree with it but
I don't you know want to start a war
so uh I let it go but
I think it's just that I'm
I tell my truth I tell the truth
I tell my truth whether it's Auntie
Richard or Pro Richard
so
um
I think that
[Music]
people surprised by that there was an
article once about the fact that Barbra
Streisand and Richard Dreyfus were the
only two Jews who talked about being
Jews and loved it and
you know didn't expect any bad stuff to
come for that and I
and I know her and we talked about it
and it never occurred to me not to talk
about being Jewish I was proud of it
and so
but it's the kind of thing that was
covered by a lot of
fear or a lot of
uh
not being candid
you know there were lots of the actors
in the earlier years who were Jewish who
wouldn't admit it
which I think is kind of silly
so we could go in all ways to start but
why don't we do a little a little bio
first because everybody knows you from
obviously jaws and close encounters and
what about Bob etc etc but can you give
me a little bit of a bio because that'll
kind of connect us to the book because
you have a sort of interesting childhood
related to politics in terms of where
you're at now
yeah
um I was
I was born in Brooklyn to a very
activist family my great aunt
assassinated Tsar Alexander in 1881.
an act which I'm very proud of
and uh
and my grandmother
[Music]
was a witness to the Triangle Shirtwaist
Factory Fire
and
walked away from that
catastrophe
and went directly to the Socialist Party
headquarters and volunteered and
eventually became Eugene Debs private
secretary
and
um
I
have always been their child
and my mother's child and uh
I once asked my mom
why were you a socialist and not a
communist
and she said better Donuts
is that a fact
that's a fact that's a fact and we lived
in Queens in an area in Queens which was
completely left-wing completely
socialist and communist and uh
the guy who was the head of the
Communist party on Long Island
was a big fat
hospital administrator named David and
he used to tell me stories about
what it was like to you know be a part
of the American Communist party and most
of the stories
dealt in
um
house silly and stupid they were
and he's talking as a present-day
communist right he's like he thought
they were just
that his group was particularly silly
and uh and he was always telling me
these stories because this is what
America was so frightened of
there was my father was asked
my father was not
a partisan
and he
he was asked
to run for the Board of Education in
Queens
we had crosses burned on our lawn
and blah blah
and so David called an executive cell
meeting
and all the top Communists in Long
Island met at his apartment
and they went downstairs to the basement
and David said okay we're here to
try to convince Norman Dreyfus to to run
for the board of education but it can't
be a communist movement it can't be
anything you know identified with us so
what do you think how should we do this
and one guy said well I think we should
do this and another guy said we should
do that and then another guy said well
speaking as a non-communist I'd like to
and everyone went
they just let him in because he was
their pal Stanley and Stanley walked
downstairs with them and he said that
was the the thing that everyone was so
afraid of in the early 50s
so
um
and also something that I don't think my
father really understood
because
my father was the head of a Jewish gang
in Brooklyn
in the 30s and every time his father
would close the candy store and move a
few blocks and reopen it
he had to fight his gang had to fight
the Irish and the Italian gangs
and and these were bloody fights and
these were sometimes to the death
like ripping out uh
antennas from cars and sticking them in
people's eyes and this was Pete prior to
the war
and then he went to the war
with his enemies
and he when they came back and he had a
violent War
and very dramatic
but when he came back he came back
not with enemies but with Brothers guys
who'd been through this experience with
him
and
and uh
I don't think that he realized that his
former enemies were now his best friends
and Neighbors
and I remember talking to one of his
friends who was
uh Italian
and I said I get it I get it you're a
totalitarian psychopath is better than
his totalitarian exactly exactly
yeah and and that's
and I laughed myself sick and so did he
and he he laughed so much that his milk
spilled up through his nose
so
I found at a very early age that most of
the partisanship
uh in American politics was nonsense
and
and I've always felt that way I
certainly
I was
at the very most I was a Democrat
at the height of my
partisan politics I was a Democrat or a
liberal
but I wasn't really
and would never have voted a straight
party ticket
and so when I started
my career talking about this stuff I
would always say that I was not
a liberal
that I was a Libo conservo
Rado
middle of the Roto
just like most of you you just haven't
given it enough thought lately
and and I hold to that to this day and I
think that most
by reducing our politics
to This Bitter and an ignorant
partisanship we do ourselves vast
disservices
and we should know better and and
nowadays
Republicans or or conservatives
can't wait to bring up
the word liberal as a curse word
and vice versa
Democrats do the same thing with
conservatives and the fact is
none of us are a straight Ticket Country
we don't do things like that
and we should know more one of the
simple reasons for knowing civics
is that you know from the get-go from
the beginning
opposing views are meant to be cherished
and if you don't
you are missing out on something that is
a remarkable
uh strength to our system that that's
supposed to be a liberal value
well it's supposed to be an American
value
so it's not just liberals
conservatives too and and and and we got
so far away from that in such a short
amount of time
that this is all uh post 60s and it's
done uh it was accomplished by what I
call the James Dean generation
the ones who were too old to take acid
with me and too young to help their
fathers in World War II
and they were without Mission they were
they were stuck in in nothingness
and like in the dean film you know he
was always yelling
you're tearing me apart
things were being demanded of him that
tore him apart and
when Brando did the wild one
he was asked what are you rebelling
against
and Brando said what have you got
and that's our tradition our our most
immediate tradition
and
by not knowing
uh the Constitution the Bill of Rights
the Declaration by not knowing the birth
tale of America
we cheat ourselves tremendously and we
change the values that are so important
and so unique to us
opposing views what other country
cherishes opposing views like we do
one country does
and that's the country that says my
right honorable opponent
when they talk in Parliament in Britain
they always address their worst enemy
with the most respect
and that's the tradition that we came
from
and for us to deny that or for us to
walk away from that
or feel in some way compelled for either
side conservative or liberal
to have
half down the other side
not enough to disagree with people
you were called upon to put them down
personally there were people
who
wouldn't consider it a good day if they
hadn't put down some liberals
as idiots
and the fact is
they're not idiots
it's in the American
political philosophy
of a republican democracy is not an
idiotic thing it's a brilliant discovery
and we change the world
and we are we've lost the pride of that
pride of that system
to
the partisanship of the Republicans or
the Democrats
George Washington said a very very
important thing
he said that the Constitution must
always be Central
and the parties
must always be peripheral
and we're living in the exact opposite
world now and that means that you you're
not a good conservative unless you're
putting down the Democrats and vice
versa you're not a good Democrat unless
you're putting down conservative
philosophy
and that's nonsense
and it's it it's horseshit and and we
should grow up and stop it well let me
let me pause you there for a moment
because I I don't know how familiar you
are with with what I do here but I mean
really what you're discussing is really
why I started this show and what I've
been trying to do for many years and uh
as as a brooklyn-born guy who grew up in
Long Island lived in it crazy La for
eight years and now I'm in the Free
State of Florida my life is actually
very much in line with with what you're
talking about right there but I want to
just jump back to to the Communist thing
for a moment because I think that'll
sort of help frame why you care so much
about the founding documents and all of
those things
um do you think that maybe in the 50s or
earlier when when these people were
avowed Communists in the United States
and it's hard for people of a younger
generation to kind of understand that
but they're really they were Communists
and they had meetings in basements and
things like that do you think to sort of
give the devil his due on that that they
felt
that the system could work enough that
it would actually make sense as opposed
to now let's say where I think a lot of
people think the system no longer
functions in a way so that communist
control over everything wouldn't work
but like your parents did they feel that
there was a way that you could exercise
enough control over this system that it
would be functional and genuinely help
people would that be a fair estimation
well let me put it this way
all during the 50s
all during the time when we were so
passionate either opposed to or in favor
of communism
um
that that feeling was not an informed
and educated feeling it was a feeling
that people gained from their poverty
from the history of their poverty both
in the old countries and and here
and
they were not looking to destroy the
American system
they were part of a legitimate
uh
what's the word
they were American Communists within a
system that accommodated American
communism and America was strong enough
and confident enough that they could say
sure be a communist who cares because
it's not going to take over our system
and and that was something that people
so easily forgot
so quickly yeah is that is that what
strikes you as as most uh the starkest
difference between the say sort of
self-proclaimed Communists or socialists
of today where it really is sort of
let's burn it down as opposed to let's
operate within the system something like
that I think I I think that it
are aware of the history of
American labor or
middle-class development or anything
you're going to know that America was
strong enough to accommodate a legal
communist system Communist Party
from the very beginning it never once
was attacked as illegitimate
the attack was
like extra it was they didn't even
include the legitimate party the
Communist party they just attacked
the that weird entity known as communism
and it was an international something
ghost-like craziness
and and
Stalin gave them good reason
to fear them
and the guys that I knew who were
communists
were always Communists because of
domestic
reasons because of the depression
because of lack of work
and things like that
they were not
um
uh educated to International
you know Marxism Etc
and that stuff can be pretty easily
dispensed with you know you don't have
to read Marcus to to understand
that it's illegit you know and it's too
bad that it wasn't allowed to just
Duke you know have a Duke out
an intellectual debate between communism
and and
it's like the the Nixon uh Khrushchev
kitchen debate that they had uh that was
important that was an important thing
and it actually really made a difference
you know they there's Nixon
um
stood up for Commodities and private
Enterprise and like that and Khrushchev
uh wanted to you know nail him to a wall
too bad
you could have learned something
[Music]
and to turn over a country's a country
as big as Russia
and turn it over completely to a bunch
of approachniks
that didn't know anything about the
Industries they were running
not a good thing and ultimately it was
gonna fail
sort of sort of sounds a little bit like
what we have now with a lot of people
that are running things that don't know
exactly what they're doing so you
mentioned that you would describe
yourself in sort of different ways you
obviously became
A-list Hollywood star for several
decades but Hollywood is known as this
you know sort of Lefty socialist
whatever place they're not too kind to
some of the ideas that you're writing
certainly about in this book about
Civics and pride in America and things
like that
um I know you think it's uh well I don't
put words in your mouth but I think you
believe it's affected your career later
but do you think it affected your career
early on I mean there was obviously a
tremendous amount of success there
uh you mean did was I frightened by its
negative effect on me yeah never Yeah by
not beaten by not just jumping in and
yes I'm just like you guys on everything
no I never it never occurred to me to be
like that it never occurred to me that I
would be hurt by it and when I have
friends who are on the other side who
are you know conservative writers and
such who say that they've been
blacklisted I like to turn to
my friend Lionel chedwin and say Lionel
you have not been out of work since
Hanoi Hilton
always working don't tell me you've been
blacklisted and and I think that there's
a kind of romance to being blacklisted
so you want in on that but we uh we play
fast and loose
with our insults and pejoratives
and we don't explain enough
I think that there's more books
that come out recently that are written
by conservatives who call liberals
um
Traders
basically Traders
and that's crazy
and any and and liberals who do the same
thing about conservatives are nuts
and they should control themselves
and one of the things about Civics is
that you learn
how to be civil and that's a controlled
way of communication
and if you can do that
you can always come out on top
all discussions
to yelling and screaming and
interrupting
you lose and we lose
do you sense that part of that is
because the culture has gone so Askew I
try not to blame all the politicians all
the time for how screwy everything seems
because they're just a function of us
and culturally we at an educational
level we don't teach a lot of these
things we don't teach Civics that well
our education obviously public education
ain't great to say the least the stuff
that now comes out of Hollywood and
through big Tech and everything else
it's often very slanted that that sort
of we're having like a cultural crisis
in a way that then leads to the
political dilemma that you're talking
about
I think it's
I don't know
whether it's the egg or the chicken I
don't know which comes first I do know
that
Hollywood has a liberal reputation
and I always cringe when I watch the
Oscars and wait for some beautiful
talented actress to say something stupid
about some
some issue
um yeah but it's to tell us that we're
all racist now come to my movie
yeah right
and it's kind of silly and and it should
be seen as silly it should not be seen
as I hate her I'll never talk to her and
I'll never go to her movies
and uh
they take it far too seriously in that
way
and
and conservatives
make it far too
serious when they were in the 50s when
all the owners of the companies were way
over to the right
and they and they would hire liberals to
write their Scripts
and and they they created a picture of
America in small town Andy Hardy ways
that was beautiful and very persuasive
and they had no women no blacks no Jews
nothing it was a Protestant small town
in America
and
was as
wrong-headed as
you can get
and
but that's okay if as long as you let
the other side have it say
you know let the conservatives have
their say and the conservatives do not
have to be Iran
they can be small town America
and
one of my favorite films
is the Oxbow incident
and that's the story of a town that goes
mad and hangs the wrong guys
and at the end of that film when the
sheriff comes and says he's not dead
he's he's at his Ranch and anyone who
participated in this
is going to be up for murder
and that's the whole town
[Music]
there's it's a complex thing it's
nothing is so simple and for us to make
uh the the claim that politics can be
simple
it's not fair it's not right
yeah do you find that there's a bit of
an asymmetry in the way if you want to
sort of be above The Fray but the way
each side might treat you if I'm not
mistaken I think in 2015 you were
spotted at the back of a Ted Cruz Rally
or something like that and and people
started calling you all these
because you're a crazy right-winger and
you know all of this stuff and I I
remember seeing that I think on YouTube
or something thinking I didn't know
anything about your politics beforehand
it didn't matter to me you're a great
actor I happen to you know now I really
like Ted Cruz I didn't like him as much
at the moment but okay you were just in
the back of the room if I can picture
the video again
um but that a certain side went crazy on
you but had it been the other way around
had you shown up to say a Hillary
Clinton rally I don't know that you
would have got hate that it's not
exactly equal I get the idea of that you
want to be above the craziness but right
now it does seem to me and I wrote my
whole first book was a defense of
liberalism of Classical liberalism uh it
does seem to me there is an asymmetry
that we're all struggling with right now
in terms of how each side behaves not to
say that the conservatives don't have
their Bad actors too
I think
I think if you can start out by thinking
that one side is inherently better than
the other
that it is
more
easy to perceive the morality of the GOP
as opposed to the Democrats
then you're nuts
because they're all equally nuts
the Democrats are and the so are the
Republicans and what happened in that
year was that I simply went to the
Republican
caucus in Iowa
to watch
and it was crazy radical
yeah
and it was
um what's his name the guy that you
mentioned look at that group just
no no not Ted Cruz it wasn't Ted Cruz
who was it no it was um uh
was it Rubio was no it wasn't a
candidate he was a a columnist a
commentator
and he you just mentioned him at the
beginning of the interview
um
uh he outed me okay he outed me he did
he wrote a column about what was Richard
Dreyfus doing at the Iowa caucuses and
then the Liberals went crazy
and all of my friends and right it's
just couldn't leave it alone and my son
who at that time was quite Young
he wrote
a piece that was on the internet
where he was saying why is my actor
father
in a position to give lessons in ethics
to America
and
and so what's her name uh uh Megan Kelly
invited us on her show when she was
still with fox
so we the two of us went on
and for me it was simply
if you're a smart person
you
scrutinize you read everything you don't
read you what what reinforces your
already assumed habits
and you know I I hold
being a high school history teacher to
be just about second to being an actor
an actor is the best thing on earth to
do
unless you're a high school history
teacher and then I would say how many
kids here in this room
have the same Politics as their parents
and whatever number of hands goes up I
say for this semester you take the
opposite View
under compulsion you do not agree with
your parents and I don't care
I want you to disagree with your parents
on everything I really love this
well it never happened so I never got to
know
and and I
I watched
I I graduated in 65.
by 69
there were kids who had the legal right
get up and leave any class that they
just disagreed with
well
that's stupid
that's a stupid thing to do you don't
turn over the future of your country to
people who are making life decisions
when they're 16 and a half
no
in retrospect not knowing that what the
16 and a half year olds were doing you
know in 69 now these people are running
the country I mean I guess this isn't
shocking where we're at huh
no it isn't you're right because what
happened was that it was the generation
that that took power after the 60s they
were the 70 70 to 72 school board
members they're the ones who thought
that they were smart enough to tell the
founding fathers to take a hike
and not educate
you know we we came up with a unique
system
and it was unique
and and we said we will educate you to
this system
and then you are obligated to pass it on
to your kids
and that was serious business
and we did that
and that didn't guarantee a republican
future or a Democratic future it said
that both sides had something to offer
and if you did for instance I would
always say as as a history buff
I would say there's no such thing as one
great history
is always at least two
can you know oppose one another
and if you don't see the
advantage to
and slow down and shut up
and listen more
are you hopeful that we'll get there
I am pretty convinced that we are in the
last
stages
of
[Music]
of the ability for America to survive
we are in an end game right now and that
is not a liberal end game or a
conservative end game
a combination of both and we are
without Mercy
and we are without forgiveness
and we have to
we have to rethink that we have to get
it back into the earliest years
of public schools so that your your
civic education is complete
by High School graduation
it has nothing to do with college or
university
and the more you explore that
the more you'll see why that's simple
and common sensical
the founders knew
everyone had to be educated to a certain
kind of participatory citizenship
and they knew that
it had nothing to do with those who
could afford to go on to University
that was creating exactly what the why
they had left the British Empire
so
if they had some
informed Pride
there they should be as proud as punch
give their youngest of their young
a real grounding in
civics
so it's interesting because I I talk
about a lot on the show how we are at
this moment what you're describing as an
end game we seem to be at a moment in
the country where we can basically go
two ways at this point we can either
figure out how to you know maintain
ourselves as the United States of
America or the states really just kind
of need to go their separate ways and
that's sort of what Federalism is about
in the first place but then what makes
us United and will we end up in
Perpetual Civil War and you know there's
a Litany of problems with that so
describe what what endgame I mean end
game can go two ways Right End Game can
be we end up in just utter chaos or
there is something that comes after end
game that's positive right
um
hopefully I suppose
if you believe that you have to
find that which we share
and not that which we which divides us
we should be proud of
opposing views we should be proud of
having dissent
and they have always been the Hallmarks
of America always until so recently that
people don't understand what history
itself is
but that's what you've got to fight you
don't have a choice between having the
United States and having chaos
because that's not a choice that's
it may be fatal it may be the worst
possible thing that could happen to us
but what we should be doing is agreeing
on the need for civics and when I went
to the Wall Street Journal I was so
shocked
that they wouldn't endorse Civics for
everyone and they said they implied to
me that
they thought that liberal teachers in
Civics had a hidden agenda
and I said a hidden agenda in civics
yeah
I said you're nuts
you're crazy there's no such thing as a
hidden agenda in the teaching of civics
you either have honest history or you
don't
you either lie your way through history
or you don't
and you eat and you are willing to tell
the truth
and if you tell the truth about the Bill
of Rights why is the Bill of Rights
called The Bill of Rights why is it in
the constitution in a way that none of
the other amendments are
and it it has there's a reason and
there's a reason
that breeds Pride
and breeds love of country
you don't have to be in the military to
have love of country
you have to know why Nathan Nathan Hale
died
you have to know why
um
George Washington tried to throw the
coin across the river
and you know those stories
and you'll know
Who You Are
and without them you don't know who you
are
and I may say that I will say that
when we divide up between
commentators that are conservative
commentators that are
liberal
we're reducing American politics and
American government and American history
to an anecdote
and it's nonsense nonsense
because there's no such thing as a pure
conservative or a pure liberal
and we always are borrowing and and
exchanging Physicians and using the
positions of your opponents we're always
doing that and should
and that and that's what's so great
about living here
you know people who come from overseas
they don't go to Norway they don't say
oh I can't wait to get to Norway I can't
wait to get to
Uganda they can't wait to get to America
because America is the only country that
offers them the opportunity to have
opportunity
nobody leaves forget who's coming nobody
leaves that's that's the weird one right
um I wanna I wanna end with one thing
that could sort of connect your your
love of history and Civics and and
clearly America to to what we know the
the career that we all know and and how
that sort of is relating to Hollywood
these days it seems like I can go on
Apple movies every day and literally
I'll just scroll and scroll and scroll
and I can't find anything new that is
interesting to me it's it's almost
impossible it feels like the the studios
are out of ideas we you know we remake
and we reboot and we retread and now you
know the Studios have all come together
and so there's just not a plethora of
ideas anymore and I end up watching the
same I actually watch What About Bob
about two weeks ago on a Sunday I end up
watching the same things that I was
always watching uh for most of my life
as a child of the 80s and the 90s
um do you think Hollywood can shift to
help with some of this that there could
be some stories I mean there's plenty
plenty of stories from our past that
could help us understand some of this
better we used to be able to tell them
but we don't seem to be able to tell
them anymore or maybe it's not Hollywood
that should be doing it
well it it's not just Hollywood that's
true but I I have found
that
there's a whole series of books
by Howard fast and
um
others who I've wanted to
to turn into films and I've been told no
no that's agit prop that was Communist
agent problem
are you crazy you're talking about some
book that was he wrote Spartacus that's
a that's a pro-communist book what are
you nuts
and yet that's how they were dismissed
and didn't a lot of the guys who wrote
that end up getting blacklisted in
Hollywood
yeah yeah they did
they were and Howard was one of them and
I went to Howard and I said when he was
in his 90s I said I'm gonna get your
stuff done
I am
and then I had to come to him
some 10 years later and say
I'm so sorry
but I I still can't get you done I can't
get it done people don't
they don't read what they what's in
front of them they read the rep
and
and I don't care anymore and I and I
don't want anyone to really care if
you're a communist and you've written a
brilliant book
like Animal Farm or 1984.
do you really think you're gonna be
poisoning the the brains of your
children what by introducing them to
could grief we have no we have no sense
of risk and we have no trust in our
children's brains
and that's a terrible terrible flaw
Richard I don't think we can end on
terrible terrible flaw we gotta end with
something positive here help me bring
help me bring this home
okay agree with me
all I want is to agree with me
well I agree with of course I agree with
the premise that we got to let go of
some of this hate and we got to stop you
know I don't know how much you know
about me but I'm married to a man with
two kids I'm pro-choice and people write
about me all day long what a what a far
right conservative I am so I get it
these labels make no sense we're all an
amalgamation of a million different
ideas I I someone born in New York only
lived in New York and La my entire life
until the last year in Florida so I
think I'm in some ways a living
breathing example of some of the stuff
that you're doing and why did I why did
I come to Florida for freedom
hahaha
well I'll tell you uh keep it up and uh
and bring it up don't limit yourself to
your whatever your partisanship is
because that's disaster and you're more
than your party affiliation and you're
more than your general
to stand up for what America introduced
to the world in 1787
is not
small thing
and it took courage on the part of the
country and it took courage on the part
of the public and
and that's what's missing we have no
sense of pride no sense of Courage no
sense of risk
and we
we and we should do things that raise up
such Pride
and that means risking the the brains of
your children
[Music]
I often end the show by saying I have
nothing better to do than save the world
I sense that's your mission too
yep that's exactly my mission
it's really been a pleasure Richard
thank you so much for taking the time
thanks a lot
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell